good morning wouldn't it be something if
all this was just an elaborate sting
operation to collect your outstanding
care slips what an operation good
morning and welcome on this Monday the
17th of a celebrate the accomplishments
of the graduating class of 2010 of the
Columbia University College of Dental
Medicine those challenges that seem so
daunting perhaps still do fading it to
the past but this is not your last
battle this just gets you in to the fray
a lot of challenges are coming but in
the years to come remember whatever
difficulty is intrude in your lives
whatever your problems are in your
practices the Columbia education will
always be there to stand between you and
mediocrity members we get that their
education here should give you the
confidence to move forward under any
circumstances we know that you will
continue to grow intellectually
technically and morally every day of
your life that is our hope for you and
like the surrogate parents that we are
that is what we expect know that you
will succeed the more you will succeed
the more you will be challenged but due
to your diligence your intelligence your
perseverance and assisted by the
irritatingly persistent nature of our
faculty if excessively negotiated the
most rigorous curriculum of any dental
school anymore you are they are a
resilient bunch of students as much as
I've tried I have not been able
it's very disappointing well you'd
become professionals we are very very
proud of all it you've earned the right
to be called doctor and colleague and
you deserve a serious round of applause
we have to take a moment of course to
recognize those in the audience or
elsewhere who have supported you
throughout these four years financially
emotionally with love and understanding
often at great personal sacrifice the
parents grandparents brothers sisters
in-laws drug spouses assorted relatives
and friends who have been so important
in your life let's give them around a
little thank you thank you keeping with
tradition we'd like to recognize our
great support staff secretary's
assistants module personnel and
administrators who by doing a terrific
job every day have kept our school
afloat without them we could not exist
you guys
and a very special thanks to Melissa
Wells and Alexander Schwartz teen to
whom we are grateful for so many
wonderful events including these
graduation ceremonies Melissa Alex
finally you may be wondering who these
people are behind me we would be remiss
if we didn't salute our wonderful
faculty and these people behind me
represent that wonderful faculty permit
me while I introduced into you in the
front row your left my right dr. Allen's
a former cola former dean of the College
of Dental Medicine and vice dean of the
center for community health partnerships
dr. Lewis Mandel assistant dean for
extramural hospital programs dr. Letty
moths Allen tine senior associate dean
for academic affairs mr. Frank
brightwell our honored guest dr. Lynn
Goldman dean of the faculty of health
sciences and medicine doctor I reveal
Amster our dean across the aisle dr.
Martin Davis associate dean for student
at alumni affairs dr. Margot Jaffe
president of the Association of dental
alumni dr. Janelle Davis Columbia
diversity chaplain dr. Ron Meyers vice
dean for clinical affairs dr. Sarah
Patterson associate dean for financial
affairs in the back row from your left
am i right dr marlin climate system ding
for special assistant dean for special
projects dr. john garvik director of the
division of oral biology dr. Christos
angelopoulos director of the division of
oral and maxillofacial radiology George
as white director of the division of
prosthodontics dr. Thomas Jane Cangelosi
director of the division of orthodontics
and chairman of the section of growth
and
element dr. Joseph McManus Dean for
admissions across the yard dr. Charles
Solomon director of the division of
endodontics dr. Stephen Justin director
of the division of pediatric dentistry
dr. Burton Adelstein chairman of the
section of Social and Behavioral
Sciences dr. dana wolf director of the
pre doctoral program in periodontics dr.
Dennis Mitchell associate dean for
diversity and multicultural affairs and
dr. Stephen Marshall assistant dean for
extramural programs I bring you
greetings from a faculty member who has
been very close to your hearts and you
to hers dr. Vickie evangelina's who
cannot be with us today she sends you
her love she sends you her
congratulations and she sends you
certainly her best wishes for the coming
years dr. this
there are other faculty here who are
intimately associated with your
education in the third and fourth years
dr. Norman fader dr. Jessica hilberg dr.
Lu Rubens dr. Katrina Catherine tamari
dr. Jeffrey Pomerance dr. mark
McCullough with dr. Stephen singer mary
lee cordis dr. IRA rosner dr. Michelle
mercy and dr. mark tenor
dr. Hawks things here too it is my
pleasure to introduce dr. Janelle Davis
who is the columbia university chaplain
director of the Earl hall Center where
she oversees the office of the
University of chaplains community impact
and the campus ministries is my pleasure
every time to introduce dr. Janelle
Davis to deliver the invocation dr.
Davis congratulations 2010 graduates as
dentist you will be trusted doctors you
will be sought out at ungodly hours for
emergency treatment and pain relief you
will be counted on for the management of
oral health and quality of life
treatments in your communities of care
you will be the first doctor that will
diagnose many treatable systemic and
chronic illnesses your work your work
will help to close gaps in health care
access and will be an essential
component of preventive health care
while words of gratitude will all too
often be unspoken know that your work
will support the daily health well-being
and dignity of your patients may each of
you have the stamina courage and the
humility to be humane Partners in Health
may you be blessed with wisdom good
humor and a peaceful spirit may it be so
may it be so with God's help amen
if you notice I'm not wearing a hood my
hood was recalled this morning I never
handed in my class 3 skill assessment so
I'm going to do that next week I promise
I promise one of the reasons that I like
to do this every year was because I get
to introduce dr. Lee Dolman dr. Goldman
is the Herald and Margaret hatch
professor of medicine in the College of
Physicians and Surgeons he's the
professor of Epidemiology in the mailman
school of public health he is the
executive vice president for the health
science and biomedical sciences and the
Dean of the faculties of the health
sciences and medicine on Tuesdays and
Thursdays he also is a crossing guard on
165th street and fort washingtonmd dr.
Goldman
it is a good time to have an extra job
whenever I'm asked to give brief remarks
I can't help but think of Abraham
Lincoln at Gettysburg because probably
no one else in the history certainly of
the US had quite such an impact in the
speech of about two minutes we all
remember he started off with memorable
four score and seven years ago and ended
with the quote of the people by the
people and for the people shall not
perish from the earth but the real gist
of his remarks which was least
apocryphal in the back of an envelope
said that no one would really remember
anything he said he was there to
consecrate a battlefield cemetery and he
thought that people remember the heroism
of people who fought and died at
Gettysburg rather than anything he said
or anybody else can say now turned out
Lincoln wasn't right about himself but
he was right about the second speaker
the second speaker and some of you may
know this was Edward Everett huben
governor of Massachusetts he spoke for
more than two hours no one remembers
anything he said our featured speaker
today could be more like Lincoln and
like add whatever let me just say that
it may seem as though you started your
education here four score and seven
years ago but it really has not been
quite that long we also know that the
skills that you've learned here for the
people will not only make them less
likely to perish but more likely to lead
happy productive and rewarding lives and
although what I say today will quickly
be forgotten the world will long benefit
from your knowledge your professionalism
and dedication so it's my pleasure to
join here today with the faculty the
administration your family and friends
to wish you all the best and to welcome
you to one of the healing professions
congratulations it's tough to be the
boss I've always said that it's tough to
be the leader and it gets tougher every
day I said that our game needs the
decisiveness at Napoleon passion and
Mother Teresa and he's taller than both
of them he has an aura of wisdom that we
all respect it was our Dean who told me
recently that I should learn from the
mistakes of others because I couldn't
possibly live long enough to make them
all myself but I try it is written that
a good leader has six defined qualities
our Dean has Ruiz honesty responsibility
confidence enthusiasm and reliability
it's my great pleasure to introduce the
dean of the college of dental medicine
doctor I reveal Amster
good good morning it's a I'm a little
overwhelmed by that introduction and it
happens once a year and this is the day
good morning this truly is a glorious
day outside the glorious day in sight as
well it really is a distinct pleasure
for me to welcome the Columbia
University College of Dental Medicine
class of 2010 their family and friends
to this graduation ceremony this day is
memorable for all of you as this
ceremony and the university graduation
to be held tomorrow mark the completion
of a rigorous four years of study first
let me tell you something about the
class of 2010 when the class entered in
the fall of two thousand six they came
with a mean entry criteria that placed
them in the top three percent of all
applicants in the United States and as a
class excuse me they ranked second of 56
dental schools in terms of admissions
criteria these are numbers that they've
heard me say before but I think a better
measure of this class isn't it is
indicated by the fact that many have
traveled to provide oral health care
services throughout the world and many
have been active participants in
research and other extracurricular
activities that includes dental dental
student organizations provision of
dental services to patients in
underserved communities and recruitment
of underrepresented minorities in high
school and college to careers in the
Health Professions following graduation
members of the class of 2010 will attend
some of the most sought-after and
prestigious postdoctoral and residency
programs in the United States at a time
like this one reflects on the past and
each year as I do at this time I want to
read a passage from an important
historical document presented in May
nineteen sixteen by a committee composed
of faculty from the College of
Physicians and Surgeons here at Columbia
and prominent dental practitioners in
New York this led to the founding of the
dental school in 1917 the document was
titled a
school on University lines and let me
quote the trustees and the Faculty of
Medicine of Columbia University have by
formal vote approved the establishment
of a school of dentistry it is proposed
to make the dental course at Columbia
one of four years the first part of
which is to be identical with and part
of the medical course a dental
dispensary providing free treatment to
the poor and opportunities for clinical
experience for the students will be one
of the features of the new school
another feature will be special research
in dental science with the medical
course is a foundation the new school
will graduate better and more
scientifically trained dentists this is
the 94th anniversary of the founding of
the College of Dental Medicine and our
school remains true the original
principles on which it was founded this
year we introduced a new curriculum that
will be the most innovative of any in
the United States this curriculum will
continue to be built around three
guiding concepts that have guided us
really for the last 30 years the first
part of the curriculum that part would
represent training in biomedical
sciences is to be taken with medical
students as it has in the past this
provides a superb foundation for these
graduates second while jet will not
generally required by our profession we
place an emphasis on the need for
postdoctoral training and ninety-eight
percent of this class will go on for
additional training the third replaced
in importance on dual degrees we have
joined programs with public health
business and education and members of
this class will you hear about today
have taken advantage of that opportunity
as for the future the class of 2010
infants the profession at a very
challenging time and in thinking about
this that remark I think that's probably
something that every single speaker at
graduation says but let me give you an
indication of why I think it's true for
our profession first it is generally
acknowledged that there is a shortage of
dentists in the United States and in
this country there is now one dentist
for about every 2,200 people for
comparison this country is considered to
have a shortage of physicians with one
physician this includes both medical
doctors and doctor
of osteopathy for every 350 people while
medicine has for the most part responded
by increasing the class sizes at medical
schools response to this shortage of
dentist has been the opening of new
dental schools in the past six years
five new schools have been established
and others are planned the new schools
are affiliated in general albia twice
loosely with osteopathic but not
allopathic medical schools these schools
place an emphasis on clinical training
with limited emphasis on biomedical
science this is a very disturbing trend
in addition the profession is faced with
other important questions including the
use of mid-level providers to improve
access to care the adoption of new
diagnostic and treatment paradigms that
are being developed with a focus on
prevention and early detection of
disease in addition many are now asking
how will we define a dental practitioner
in the future how does the dental
practitioner of the future become fully
integrated into the healthcare system
and I think Jenelle Davis addressed that
in her remarks these are just some of
the issues that will be faced by the
class of 2010 to our graduates I urge
you to remain in contact with the
college some of you will continue your
training here at Columbia others will
attend programs elsewhere in new york
city in the north northeast or across
the country your experiences here
however will define you in many ways is
important for you and for us that you
remain part of the College of Dental
Medicine in closing allow me to express
personally on an on behalf of the
faculty and staff the college and the
university our sincerest congratulations
and our very best wishes for a very
successful future thank
thank you dr. laughter our next guest is
dr. Margot H Jaffe you earned her dds
degree from Columbia University
certificate in pediatric dentistry from
Columbia University and an orthodontic
certificate from Columbia University she
is a true daughter of Columbia
University it's an all-time friend
active and effective president of the
Association of dental alumni and so true
to the tradition that she wrote her
remarks on the back of an envelope like
Abe Lincoln it's a pleasure to introduce
dr. Margot Jaffe
it is my pleasure today to speak to you
on behalf of the columbia university
college of dental medicines Alumni
Association I want to congratulate the
entire class of 2010 and you're thrilled
and supportive families you represent
the best and brightest dental graduates
in the United States and your
accomplishments should fill you with
pride and exhilaration although your
formal graduate education is complete
the majority of you are pursuing
postgraduate residences and specialty
training programs this is consistent
with the long-standing tradition of our
students seeking additional knowledge
and expertise in addition to the
rigorous didactic education that you
have mastered we the faculty have
imparted in you a firm value system with
ethical tenants that will remain a core
foundation to build upon our goal of
creating competent confident and
compassionate young clinicians has been
realized we the alumni are your
colleagues and your advocates use us as
a resource the Association serves as a
bridge between dental school and your
future professional endeavors we hope
that we have fostered a sense of loyalty
to the Columbia family and count on your
future participation stay in touch
attend our alumni events and see
e-courses volunteer mentor teach and
when you are able contribute to the
institution that prepared you well for a
promising professional career good luck
to all of you
I didn't know you guys were that good
our next speaker is young talented
articulate reasonable and responsible
unusual in the student he has
represented his class with dignity
dedication never adversarial always
cooperative mature his future is bright
there is no doubt that he will be a
credit to columbia university and the
profession he will remain as a college
of dental ins College of Dental Medicine
in the orthodontics program we have to
keep an eye on him he is quite a catch
leave me Jeremy's unica president of the
senior class
getting off a subway this morning I
stepped in a huge wad of gum and it was
going to be a good day Dean Goldman Dean
Lamster fellow faculty members
distinguished guests friends family
members and the class of 2010 the day we
have long been looking forward to has
finally arrived today surrounded by
those who have helped us through these
four years and with memories of those we
have lost along the way we step forward
into the world as responsible caring and
compassionate professionals the elite
academic education we received since
arriving in 2006 will prepare us to be
leaders in our profession and our
communities at Columbia University
College of Dental Medicine we are one of
a small group of dental schools that
combine both the medical and dental
curriculum into an intense two-year
period for those of you who got off the
subway this morning on Broadway and pass
the library just across the street and
enter the armory in Fort Washington you
pretty much figured out where our first
two years are spent at that time we did
not venture further than this two block
radius sad as that may be we were not
studying for an exam or practicing for
an opera crackle we were making a mess
in the wet lab trying to pour up our
complete dential finer impressions there
was a multitude of feelings at that time
yes we were learning a tremendous amount
and had the opportunity to learn from so
many great talented and experienced
faculty faculty members from both the
medical and dental school but it was a
grueling and taxing time there was
little time for friends outside of your
dental classmates and relationships were
just as hard to manage after spending 40
hours a week with your classmates they
quickly became your ad closest friends
yes at times we were felt like we were
back in high school with a gossip of who
was dating whom and the competition to
get the attention of the professor's but
from that time together strong
friendships developed I had previously
heard that only friends that a dentist
has are well other dentists and after
spending the first two years here I can
see how this happens with little time to
venture out beyond washing heights but
from this we develop friendships with an
incredibly talented group of people and
friendships that will last a lifetime we
learned an extraordinary amount of
information in our first two years here
even though some of our information I've
been forgotten while studying for that
next exam or practicing for that next
practical waxing up that final denture
the few things I will never forget are
the good times remember how our entire
class came together for the orientation
talent and auction fundraiser how can
you forget listen Ada and armando's
passionate salsa dance Oh Jen races
serenade to not only one but two of our
fellow classmates yes then there was a
surprise quarry evident choreographed
dance with jeff z and myself and thanks
to youtube we will always have these
memories then there was the late dr.
michael you on who spunk and pizzazz for
life and for learning touched the lives
of so many within our class and here at
columbia dr yuan was an incredibly
generous as well as part of the
orientation fundraiser he volunteered to
cook for 12 students a three-course meal
complete with servers and menus on top
of this he did it twice and mind you
this was all on his one-bedroom New York
City apartment dr. you on I know you're
with us in spirit today and on behalf of
the class of 2010 we'd like to say thank
you for all you have done
I for one could not be more proud to be
following in your footsteps next year
concluding our second year our
close-knit hard working classes world
was comprised of lecture halls libraries
the preclinical lab and the occasional
starbucks along the way then something
happens as we completed pathophysiology
and the medical curriculum the cage of
Washington Heights was unlocked and we
got to venture out wow did our worlds
change starting the summer third year we
began our oral surgery clerkships at
hospitals throughout the five boroughs
and New Jersey and with that came our
first patient experiences my mannequin
head from the first two years whom I
named Pedro now spit talked complained
and had an unusually large annoying
tongue to further supplement our
clinical experiences Columbia initiated
a newly organized program called the
global health externship which helped
which helped fund Columbia students are
taking in dental health programs around
the world these externships served under
privileged populations in places like
the Dominican Republic Cambodia the
Philippines Jamaica Guatemala and even
as far as western Virginia of the 76
members of the graduating class 75%
participated in these externships and
many participated in more than one I was
fortunate enough to participate in somos
amigos trip to the dominican last june
and came back humbled and grateful in
the rural mountains two hours outside of
santiago and 30 miles from the haitian
border this organization has
successfully established a full medical
and dental clinic that that is fully
intertwined and embraced by the
surrounding community from day one my 10
fellow classmates three colombia dental
residents dr. furin and members of the
somos amigos dove headfirst for three
and a half exhausting but satisfying
days from these global health
externships not only did our clinical
skills start to improve but we gained
more calm
and we started to get the idea of what
being a practitioner is all about it is
not only just about treating patients
like my mannequin Pedro it's about
compassion communication and the skills
to not only diagnose but to deliver
treatment in a timely fashion we started
here at Columbia dental in august of
2006 with our goal to become dentists
and after four years we are coming away
with so much more than a dental degree
after four years of learning traveling
around the world volunteering and
treating patients today we leave the
shelter to block radius of the heights
to the class of 2010 we did it and as a
mando so greatly put it in his speech in
the Dominican we did it together we
should take comfort and be proud that we
leave Colombia with an elite education
and training along with friendships with
some of the most talented skilled and
compassionate dentists who we are lucky
to call our professors and our
classmates congratulations to the
Columbia dental class of 2010 and thank
you for an amazing four years together
Thank You Jeremy our guest speaker this
morning is dr. Frank bright well dr.
bright will received his BA degree from
Georgetown University and his ms from
loyola in Baltimore is the founder and
director of somos amigos medical
missions what began 20 years ago as a
six-week trip for group of high school
students has grown into a medical
mission serving the community of el
dinero and hito in the dominican
republic each medical mission consists
of six physicians six dentists in the
cadre of 40 or more volunteers who in
less than five days service close to
1,000 patients in this remote
economically poor and underdeveloped
region it is my great honor to introduce
Frank brightwell
well it's official i have been
introduced as dr. now Dean Lamster I I
was kind of hoping that an honorary
degree would be a part of this deal and
if not I've got nine patients lined up
for thursday i'm going to have to
reschedule maybe I really should
apologize because I think maybe my only
qualification for being here today with
you is that dutifully for most of my
adult life I have lost every day and by
the way now that I'm here with you today
and a part of this circle can I finally
find out the secret where do you go when
you leave the room just for a moment
well indeed the bar has been set high
for today I listened once to a
commencement address by maya angelou
when she said I learned that people will
forget what you said people will forget
what you did but people will never
forget how you made them feel and so for
a brief moment to the graduates I ask
you to take in this whole scene and
think of how you feel my hope is that on
this incredible day you feel giddy with
the realization of all that you've
accomplished and for everything that
lies ahead and maybe you need to feel a
pinch to this is real this is it this is
your day that's right Paul pinch this is
your day I'll soon be an afterthought
and asterisk on your special day and
indeed it's such an honor and a
privilege for me to be here with you to
share a few minutes of your joy and so
if you'll indulge me I would like to
tell you a few stories for most of my
life I've been involved in secondary
education working with lots of young
people if I talk about someone named her
me will you all know who I'm talking
about to this day a plastic her me
figure sits on my desk
and next to him some small instruments
and a large plastic tooth you see her me
was one of the elves on that holiday
classic Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer
and see if you remember this exchange
again if you'll indulge me and okay
admittedly it's not quite from the pages
of fur ours a treatise on the
irregularities of the teeth and their
corrections but I hope it makes a point
the scene is in the elf workshop in the
head elf and her me are talking in the
head of so elf says to her me why
weren't you at elf practice her me says
I was just fixing these dolls teeth just
fixing now listen we have dolls that cry
talk walk blink and run a temperature we
don't need any chewing dolls her me says
but I just thought I'd find a way to to
fit in you'll never fit in now you come
back to elf practice learn how to wiggle
your ears chuckle warmly go hehe and ho
ho and important stuff like that a
dentist could grief and he leaves and he
slams the door I've always used that
story when I'm working with young people
who have a dream but whose dreams don't
always match those of others in their
life in my case I've never been one to
do something just because it's what
people have expected to be honest I
really hate following the rules and so
if i can offer you some tidbits of
wisdom today the first would be don't
follow the rules listen to your heart
trust your gut and follow your dreams
make your own rules I know it sounds
very clich but trust me you are the
only person who gives yourself the
permission to do that and you have to
start today I guess my the best example
of my following my dreams is ultimately
what leads me to being here with you
today he heard a little bit of it about
20 years ago I was working at a school
outside of the DC in the DC area and the
colleague and I started this summer
service program for high school students
we would build roads and schools and
water systems
with the students and after a few years
of prodding I finally talked my own
position and my own dentist into joining
us for a few days that was 13 years ago
now and today somos amigos medical
missions has grown to be the primary
care for about three thousand people who
live in the rural area we serve and what
happens on that mountainside in the
Dominican Republic truly is amazing we
have three buildings that are now our
permanent facility impressive diagnostic
capabilities a pharmacy that rivals a
Duane Reade and we're literally saving
lives and we're certainly helping
hundreds of people with chronic
illnesses and other conditions live
healthier and more comfortable lives but
you know it's really our dental care
that perhaps sets us apart most from
other organizations we typically have
several general dentists in our group we
do root canals we do oral surgery we
even make dentures right on site a
couple years ago Armando heard of somos
amigos through a high school classmate
and gave me a call he said he was trying
to find ways to help his Columbia
classmates in him find opportunities to
do service work in other countries we
chatted a couple times by phone and the
next thing you knew I was here with some
of my colleagues meeting with dean
Lamster Dean Martin and some others and
a relationship was born and today for a
week a year Columbia faculty residence
students staff our dental clinic I just
want to thank Armando you're a
remarkable person in many ways Armando
and I want to thank you for your vision
and your determination and your
commitment a few stories if I can about
our clinic and inevitably some of them
involve the language barrier between our
professionals and the patients were
serving one of our dentists his name
might convince key now Mike is a big guy
he's very earnest he's very serious he's
very pious but he has a huge heart
before we had our nice facilities we
operated our clinic out of the chapel in
the community we were there for years
before we eventually moved on to the
school and for three years or four years
Mike was it he was our only dentist and
at least for a couple of those years we
had no electricity
no running water Mike's patients would
sit either in a tip back rocking chair
that was propped up with cement blocks
or on a lawn chair on the altar of the
chapel and all he could do in those
first couple years was pull teeth the
first word he learned in Spanish was
bien and that was the only word he knew
for a while on his first trip bloodied
and sweaty from hours of extracting
teeth under the crucifix he would
repeatedly say bien bien bien as he
yanked out teeth from the horrified
patients who were in intense pain and he
would toss the T cynthy teeth into his
extraction bucket when he came back the
second year Mike had a much broader
Spanish vocabulary that included two new
words abre and cierra open and close
well maybe you see where this is going
while attempting to use this newly
weren't learned words on one of his
patients he unfortunately mixed them up
and so what began as a small command to
open your mouth abre became Sahara and
that became louder and louder abello as
of Sierra Sierra has the patient for
patient was biting down on Mike's
fingers harder and harder as hard as he
could and quenching the arms of the
chair as if for dear life the heart of
the patient bit the louder Mike would
say cierra cierra another story
involving Margaret Murphy she was our
first hygienist and has been with us
many times she reminds me of a
leprechaun Margaret has five kids and
she's one of the sweetest people you'll
ever meet and it must have been her
second trip as her next patient was
waiting to take the seat with her very
basic understanding of Spanish she
thought she overheard the patient saying
that he remembered Margaret from the
previous year and she said something in
her broken Spanish that since he was
back again well it must have been a good
experience for him well he interpreted
that as her flirting with him and so he
turned to Margit and said in his Spanish
look I already have three girlfriends
and a wife no more a Margaret turned
probably five shades of red
and the patient can only continue to say
over the home of the cavitron wow wow
and then the last story there was a man
in his late 70s who came to our clinic
he had no teeth and in a way that
remains miraculous and mysterious to me
to this day our folks made him dentures
you wouldn't believe the smile on his
face when he saw himself in the mirror
for the first time now with teeth after
so many years and with the twinkle in
his eye he looked at us he winked a bit
and he let us know this T great is back
in business it's actually when I see
some of our younger adult patients some
of whom have never been to a dentist
before when I appreciate even more of
the words from Don Quixote every tooth
in a person's head is more valuable than
a diamond you all know that there's a
museum of dental art in Paris it's named
after Pierre fo shard someone I've
learned lay the foundation for much of
modern dentistry but that concept of
dentistry as an art really resonates
with me when I'm in our clinic and I'm
walking around observing the work that
our dentists do I'm in awe I've gained
such an appreciation for the art indeed
for your ability to see what I can't see
and I appreciate your striving for
perfection always in the interest of the
patient I witnessed extraordinary
measures to alleviate pain and to give
someone their smile back countless hours
hours hunched over a patient's mouth
incredible patience some of our patients
especially the Haitians come to us after
never having been to a dentist before
they can spend hours with us for 6-8
hours as our dentists do all they can
because they know my this might be the
only opportunity they have to work with
this person you have such a profound
opportunity to change a person's life
giving someone the ability and the
confidence to smile again without pain
without discomfort such a beautiful
thought and that's what you do you do it
with compassion and empathy there's one
lesson in hearing about the clinic in
the Dominican Republic it would be this
that one person you and the person
sitting next to you and the next one
person really can make a difference our
clinic started as an idea a silly idea
maybe and now 3,000 people rely on us
for their medical and their dental care
and we're all that they have literally
in the region to put it in perspective
in the region that we serve which
includes dozens of communities and towns
there's one public hospital the one
public hospital has one dentist who
comes for one day every month one
dentist one day a month period we didn't
get to where we are overnight though
with our digital x-rays our autoclaves
our high-speed hand pieces with whatever
you call that optical stuff inside it's
taken many people many years to get to
where we are and it hasn't been easy
what it's taken is our staying true to
our mission to our goal and to our dream
people still say to us oh you can't do
that you can't do that but remember I
make my own rules granted financially we
live trip to trip and we really give a
new definition to grassroots but we're
making a difference one patient at a
time and I've been witness to the
incredible goodness of people simple
people who naively believe they can
change the world there are people who
believe in this thought and I wish I
knew to whom I could attribute it to the
world you may be just one person but to
one person you may be the world I can't
tell you about my work in the Dominican
Republic without mentioning my recent
trip to Haiti and my time there was so
overwhelming it was so emotional so
profound that I hope you won't mind if I
read you a little bit from a blog that I
wrote while I was there it's from day 5
in Jacmel which is a city leveled by the
earthquake with the help of a hired
motorcycle we were determined to dig
deeper
into the remains of Jacmel a boy wearing
an Obama t-shirt and carrying a bucket
of water caught our eyes and suggested
with his eyes that we follow him down
the street completely impassable to cars
because of the piles of debris we
entered a small courtyard where they're
obviously stood several houses before
the earthquake we met the boy's mother
Daphne and his three younger siblings in
the courtyard there were other women and
many young children but we didn't see
any men oblivious to any sense of
modesty Daphne lifted her tattered shirt
several times to wipe away the tears as
she recalled the earthquake her husband
and the father of her four children died
in a spot near where we said a spot
marked only by falling blocks and
twisted rebar and the only clothes
Daphne and her children now owned with
what they were wearing her son's obama
shirt offered am a generic to a world
that they would never know as she wept
and recounted the 20 seconds that would
change her world the other women and
children gathered around some of the
adolescents turned their heads and
feigned smiles in embarrassment and the
other woman clutched their younger
children as if to reassure they too had
relived that day many times apart from
the sobbing the silence was painfully
loud in this small courtyard 27 people
died husbands and fathers mothers and
wives and children the one could only
imagine the horrific sounds that broke
the silence on that day surely not all
27 died instantly although perhaps that
would have been a blessing the screams
of agony and helplessness the cries of
loss and surrender echoed around us
Daphne and her children and her
neighbors still hear those sounds as if
January 12th were yesterday and why do I
bring this up of course because Daphne
deserves to be remembered and because I
promised her that I would
but I tell you her story not to make you
feel bad or guilty to make you feel a
little bit uncomfortable yes I think
that's a to remind you how fortunate you
are and that there's a bigger world out
there that there are people suffering
and that for some people the concept of
going to a dentist would be the least of
their worries your obligation and my
request of you is simply this to
remember daphne and all the other ones
like her out there in haiti and in the
dominican republic and in new york city
and in your homes in your hometowns even
in your success always live your life
with the conscience yonder Hartog a
Dutch playwright and social critic said
don't commit the error common among
young people by assuming that if you
can't save the whole of mankind you
failed because you see none of us none
of us on our own is going to save the
world but what we can do is connect with
others in meaningful ways reaching out
to them and solidary and and peace with
whatever gifts we have whether that's
dentistry or something far more modest
but if each of us feels that we can't
make a difference and we might as well
just pack up now and go home in addition
to encouraging you to live your lives
with the conscience a few other life
lessons if you'll indulge me a couple
moments longer go about your life and
especially your work with the sense of
humility make yourself vulnerable
sometimes so that you can relish in its
serenity be a person of integrity
shortcuts are okay when you have to make
the movie on time but not when you're
doing the business of life appreciate
simplicity and allow yourself the
liberation of experiencing it sometimes
nurture the compassion that rests in
your soul always remember that there is
a person attached to that tooth that
you're working on don't take yourself
too seriously laughs
okay maybe not at all of Jeremy's jokes
but laughs sometimes and smile and
finally love know that life's journey is
only half complete if you don't share
yourself with someone else you're so
capable so bright so full of life and
hope and gifts that you can't even see
in yourselves and we're all so proud of
you share all of that with others with
your patients and the other people who
are going to come into your lives
especially others to whom life has not
been as kind I can leave you with just
one more hermie reference at the end of
that half-hour program the misfit toys
have all been rescued Rudolph is leading
the sleigh the abominable snowman has
been tamed and everyone goes happily on
their way and Rudolph says to her me
goodbye her me whenever a dentist is I
hope someday you'll be the greatest and
so that's my final wish to you I hope
that someday you'll be the greatest
you're certainly well on your way
congratulations
thank you
dr. Lenny Moss salen tyne our senior
associate dean for academic affairs she
keeps me in line she tells me what I
have to do and what I have to do it and
I'm thankful to her for keeping me on
that straight and narrow path dr. letty
more salen tyne or present the cigarette
teaching award I want to join in
extending my congratulations to all the
graduates to the parents relatives and
friends and indeed also to my colleagues
on in the faculty because you did it but
you did it with our help so here it is
my pleasant duty to recognize a member
of the faculty for his or her excellent
contributions to the curriculum of the
college the award is named after a
former dean of the school dr. Edwards
sega rally and the selections made by a
committee with representation from
alumni faculty students the curriculum
committee and the deans of academic and
student and alumni affairs this year's
recipient of the advert sega rally Award
for Excellence in teaching is dr. Joseph
McManus
sony thanks
dr. McManus in addition to it being
snappy dresser is truly a lifelong
learner a perpetual student in addition
to his dental degree which he earned
many years ago he has earned for
additional master's degree one as
recently as last year dr. McManus is a
conscientious teacher with a great sense
of humor in addition he is an ethical
professional who serves as a outstanding
role model for our students our
selection for this award was made before
we received the announcement that dr.
McManus is leaving us to assume a
leadership position in the American
Dental Association in that position I
think he will miss teaching and we will
miss him congratulations dr. McManus and
best wishes
dr. McManus will be missed and now we
move to the reason that we're all here
today the presentation of the diplomas
that you've all earned would ask dr.
Lamster dr. salant I'm dr. Davis and dr.
Myers to join me up here as you know the
graduates will move across the platform
they'll stop here have their hoods
placed then they'll proceed to dr.
Lamster who will present their
certificates dr. salen time will present
their pins and then they will go off to
the right there are some of our students
who have invited sorted relatives
friends family to assist in the hooding
we would ask those people come up on the
right and depart on the left I will call
their names as they come up we're
pleased to again announce a tradition
that began last year we will be
presenting each student with a gold
label pin with the dental school acorn
logo engraved on it the idea for this
gift was a was initiated by alumni Chris
Bonacci who felt that it's important for
graduates to receive a significant and
enduring memento of the College of
Dental Medicine which they can proudly
wear it alumni functions and dental
meetings for years to come dr. salant I
will distribute the pins let's begin
dr. Samuel in edison
you
dr. david p el faro
dr. Rajesh I mean
Oh
dr. Liz nay de arjona if you'll be
hooded by her mother dr. yoni Calogero
that's good that's good enough
dr. Hugo resile a sirsa
dr. Michael lucky oh word Allah
dr. Mary L Ballard's
dr. Simon Balin
dr. Phillip K Brenton
dr. Paul a can tell me
ok
somebody's in Paul's seat thank you
dr. erika park jang dr. Chang will be
hooded by her dad dr. Choong sik Chang
was day
dr. ray cheng
dr. Jung Suk Joe
dr. eunsuk joy
dr. Victor twang
dr. Jenny Yuen Chung Chung
dr. gina Marie coo chiara that the couch
ER will be hooded by dr. Dina's irani
dr. nuyen see tongue
dr. richard panting dela Rosa
dr. Emily seed Reisman will be hooded by
a mom dr. Shelley dries Minh
dr. Jacob eyes and offer
always a crowd pleaser
nice nice you look nice Jacob dr.
Jacqueline be Fisher
dr. Whitney Diane florin dr. florin will
be hooded by her father dr. Jack Warren
congratulations dr. Ezra Friedman
dr. dr. Elena Gabriella heard we car
dr. tomorrow f gruen bound
dr. kalo he guevara
dr. Joseph M Haynes Joseph will be
hooded by his mother Christine D Haynes
you
Amanda M hochstein dr. Amanda M
hochstein be hooded by her father dr.
Jeffrey Hochstein who was a member of
the CDM faculty
now absolved the wall responsibility
Patricia wai-hung
what
Patricia just reminded me that I forgot
to call her doctor so you go back to the
seed come up again and dr. Patricia why
dr. Aaron huh
dr. Raymond T Joan
dr. Elias Kamal Joseph dr. josephs will
be hooded by his brothers dr. Salim
josephs graduated in 2006 and dr. Philip
josephs class of 2008 we expect a huge
return on this investment Jenna static
dr. bum q Kim
congratulations
HC dr. Jung Chang Kim
spectra things
dr. John hick Kim
dr. min hick Kim
nicely
dr. min jin kim
dr. mina catherine kim dr. Kim will be
hooded by her father dr. Singh bumpkin
graduate of the CDM class in 1984 our
uncle's sing good Kim is sitting out
there in the audience somewhere
dr. Eugene em co dr. Cole will be hooded
by his dad dr. Steven co not easy
putting his heart
dr. Flavio a guitar that the guitar will
be hunted by his dad dr. Flavio Paola
guitar
dr. Nicole Madison Lambert
dr. kejuan Lee
dr. lauren nicole lee
dr. Charlie T levy dr. levy will be
hooded by his dad dr. Erwin levy member
of the CDM faculty
where's Monica
dr. Barry chi Chi Linh dr. Lin will be
hooded by his sister dr. Sylvia Lynn
glass of 2007
yes this is dr. Michael Sealy the reason
for the delay was his name was listed as
Monica and I through me doesn't look
like Monica although in the dress who
knows this one I got dr. Courtney are
Logan
dr. Jo ma
dr. miles a Mason
dr. bond sorry ke moti
dr. vin h know
dr. Jeffrey a Nicolini
dr. mario h nortek
dr. Aisling Patricia O'Connor
acutely
good show
dr. Nancy okeke
dr. Jeanne Arlene oh dear old
dr. Lorelai a Paris
dr. mark h pan
dr. Jung Hyung park
tough group
dr. Minjae Park
dr. sarah s park
perfectionist
dr. Steben yogendra Patel
dr. Amanda rotana and Carlo again to be
in Florida together lock up the children
Jennifer dr. Jennifer Noel raised
yes
dr. benelli Roy
dr. Maxim cerebro
dr. Kimberly Beth gross soleimani
dr. Scott Jacen Solo Scott will be
hooded by his father dr. Steven solo
dr. Wayne a meal Stevens Wayne will be
hooded by his father dr. Patrick Steven
this
you
training training it's all training
dr. Ryan Turner
Ryan will be hooded by his dad dr. Lance
Turner whoops
ambulette is right outside
that's why we're ready for anything
dr. Virginia Turner
dr. z wang
dr. robert jay Weinstock
I'll wait for them to finish they done
doctors wings you like TMZ back there
dr. jeremy m zuniga ebony that's all
folks
you thank you
thank you
and
that wasn't so hard wasn't now thank you
all for being here and showing support
for the class of 2010 please join us
immediately after for a reception in the
Hall of Fame area on the lobby level
please return your gowns to the
appropriate area please remain in your
seats until the processional has left
the arena please do not throw objects or
shout epithets at us as we pass by be
well do good work and keep in touch
thank you and good afternoon
you